ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Carnegie Mellon University interim
president Farnum jehan Ian thank you and
good evening
wasn't that a fabulous video what a
compelling look at just a few students
and faculty who are poised to change the
world before I get started a couple of
questions for you are you excited to be
here all right
we're gonna have to do this again
because this is my fourth speaking
engagement today so are you excited to
be here are you having fun much better
much better on behalf of an entire
university community welcome to our 50th
anniversary celebration we also heard
from four fantastic CMU legends dis
afternoon Egon Marilyn
Raj you are role models who exemplify
the CMU spirit and I'm grateful for your
reflections and Jim roar our Chairman
thank you for sharing what CMU has meant
to you and for your exceptional
leadership of our board of trustees
let's give him a round of applause
what a day this has been as I look at
this crowd I'm in awe of this community
and all that it represents the passion
the ingenuity the creativity and the
pride you are Carnegie Mellon your
passion fuels this great University and
thank you for being here to mark this
occasion as we celebrate the last 50
years we also have been looking toward
our future this morning we open the
interactive Founders exhibition an
extraordinary showcase of exciting work
from more than a hundred faculty plus
their research and creative teams if you
haven't had a chance to stop by you'll
get a chance to explore it at the end of
this event this evening and I hope yet
you'll return tomorrow to experience it
fully it is unbelievable and at our
student exposition exhibition 30 student
groups showed us their vision for the
future and what a thrilling vision it is
it's offered just a small sample of how
CMU students are building dreaming and
impacting the next 50 years and we
benefited from the wisdom of our faculty
and alumni through several panels
focused on the people and ideas that set
CMU apart it's been truly an inspiring
day since Carnegie Mellon is an academic
institution and I'm a faculty member
it's only fitting that I begin tonight
with a bit of a history lesson
this weekend commemorates our 50-year
anniversary as a comprehensive research
university as you heard from Kate during
that fantastic reading of the
anniversary anthem yeah we can give her
another round of all you can do it she's
fabulous
our celebration honors the founder in
each of us every member of this
community who has helped to shape the
exceptional institution we are today
certainly this is a tribute to Andrew
Carnegie and Richard and Andrew Mellon
who created the institutions that became
eventually became CMU but the founders
theme also celebrates and empowers the
founders of today who are boldly taking
us into the next 50 years of course our
history dates back much farther than
1967 this institution began in 1900 when
Andrew Carnegie made the first of many
philanthropic gifts to establish
Carnegie technical schools which later
became the Carnegie Institute of
Technology 13 years later Andrew and
Richard Mellon founded the Mellon
Institute of industrial research by the
way while we hear a lot about Andrew
Mellon Richard B D Mellon was equally
was an equally powerful figure in the
history of Pittsburgh and CMU his son
Richard King Mellon would eventually
become the primary financial founder of
supe which became our Heinz College and
the Richard King mellon foundation
continues to invest in the future of
southwestern Pennsylvania and provides
generous support to Carnegie Mellon
University to this day as CIT and the
Mellon Institute evolve over the first
half of the 20th century they became
major players in western Pennsylvania
Carnegie Tech was well known for its
hands-on approach to learning with a
wealth of machine shops studios and labs
it also pioneered degree programs in
music art design and drama in fact the
first drama degree was awarded in 1914
at Carnegie Tech and a Mellon Institute
became widely recognized for its role in
creating the scientific advances that
stablished major industries
when Paul Mellon proposed a major merger
of these two powerhouse institutions and
a legacy of two influential families it
was neither preordained nor without
controversy in fact following the merger
in 1967 the early years of CMU were a
bit rocky and yet no one could agree
today no one could argue today rather
that the creation of Carnegie Mellon
University has been anything less than a
spectacular success
would you please join me in thanking all
of those trustees and university leaders
for decades whose dedication and careful
stewardship has shaped our institution
over the past half a century
this is when I make our marketing
communications folks nervous I'm gonna
go off script for a moment one of those
leaders who was truly astonishing
astonishing job in in shaping this
institution was my predecessor mark
Hamlin who is here with us tonight with
his wife Charlie I want to thank Mark
for all that he has done for this
institution and of course Jerry Cohen
who couldn't be here with us tonight the
former president and everything that
mark has done for me personally to make
me the person I am leaving this
institution at this moment thank you
mark and dr. Charlie
[Applause]
back to my script looking back this was
more than a merger it marked an
inflection point an action that truly
defined our future and set us down a
path to what CMU has become today it was
a defining moment that reshaped our
intellectual and geographical ambitions
generation of students and faculty have
since built upon that legacy today we're
an institution that's expanding
scientific inquiry and changing the way
that science is done both at the Mellon
College of Science and across the
university were shaping modern culture
with forward-thinking artists musicians
actors designers and architects were
paving the way to world a world where
autonomy has become an integral part of
our everyday life we're integrating the
humanities with engineering public
policy and business to meet the demands
of a changing global economy and we're
offering a distinctive educational
experience that prepares a new
generation of leaders to imagine broadly
think critically and work
collaboratively I often wonder how do
students and faculty who were here at
the founding of CIT
and the men on Institute would react to
Carnegie Mellon of today I bet it would
feel quite different to them at first
but beneath the surface what fueled our
origin still remains part of our DNA
every day we continue to fulfill the
aspiration of those early years and
build the foundation for the next round
of breath breakthrough moments I want to
share just a few examples with you when
Andrew Carnegie founded the Carnegie
tactical in schools Pittsburgh was in
the middle of a monumental boom you
actually just heard that from Jim Rohr
providing the materials and labor that
drove
economy of the entire country today
after nearly three decades later when
Pittsburgh was almost written off as a
place whose glory days were in the past
this city has reinvented itself as the
center of a new economy Carnegie Mellon
is playing a leading role in this
reinvention as another example let's
think about Andrew Carnegie's original
vision he founded his school aimed at
educating the children of factory
workers an institution that would
provide opportunities to both men and
women we have expanded that the spirit
of inclusion to incorporate a broader
view of diversity that is exceeding our
most bullish expectations today CMU is
an exceptionally multinational and
multicultural community 22% of our
undergraduates and 60% of our graduate
students are international students
representing hundred and nine countries
and for the first time in the history of
our university fifty one percent of our
incoming undergraduates this year were
women
that includes half over the first-year
students in the school of computer
science and 43 percent of our first-year
students in the college of engineering
these figures represent two to three
times the national average for these
fields and not to be outdone Bob Damon
the first year class in Tepper is more
than 57 percent female to say we're
beaming with pride is an understatement
our interdisciplinary culture
Ilse is also rooted in our past our
early years emphasized Applied Science
and design but also made sure our
students were educated into humanities
social science and in the arts today
students from across the globe travel
here to study in both disciplinary and
interdisciplinary programs
unlike many conservatories or art
schools the five schools within the
College of Fine Arts connect their
students with peers across the entire
campus community and our humanities and
Social Sciences bridge the gap between
technology and the people who use it
from ethicist who consider how
automation should be integrated into
society to learning scientists who study
how technology can improve educational
outcomes Dietrich College works at the
interface of humanity and technology and
the Heinz College is using research at
the intersection of policy management
and technology to address the social and
economic needs of a changing workforce
and finally the last example when Andrew
and Richard Mellon founded the Mellon
Institute in 1913 its mission was to
provide research services for corporate
partners industrial partnership remains
a critical piece of CMU's impact on the
world more than 350 companies
from google to disney to Ober to General
Electric to Delphi have partnered with
us in the past five years our faculty
and students have started hundred and
forty eight companies and raised more
than 1 billion in venture capital home
to top ranked business programs in the
tappers school we have a robust
entrepreneurial culture our short Center
for Entrepreneurship connects all parts
of the university to resources that
accelerate the transfer of
groundbreaking ideas to practice
revisiting this history reminds us just
how deeply our future is connected to
our past Andrew Carnegie and Andrew and
Richard Mellon truly set the tone
they were unapologetically ahead of
their time committing to seizing
opportunities and resilient in the face
of a rapidly expanding world those are
still the qualities that motivate us
today consider the many ways that our
lives have been enhanced by CMU founders
in fact Raj Reddy and other colleagues
have alluded to some of them the website
did you see did you just entered your
private information it was made more
secure by cyber security solutions
invented here the programs for this
event that you're holding it was
designed using Adobe software created at
a company founded by a CMU along CMU
dreamers and doers have made so much
possible including the Wi-Fi streaming
this event to our Silicon Valley campus
the emoji you just text it to your
sister the tsa PreCheck you enjoyed on
your flight here I know there's a hint
of sarcasm there thank you
the autonomous uber you took to get to
our campus and the tickets to Hamilton
you finally were able to get you are
welcome because of our culture of
interdisciplinary collaboration and
relentless creativity Carnegie Mellon
has become a pioneer in many emerging
fields we essentially created the field
of artificial intelligence and have
spent decades building a culture where
we use computation and data intensive
approaches to solve real world problems
and shape public policy our school of
design has taken the lead in transition
design a new area of research that
innovates design LED solutions for a
more sustainable future our expertise in
3d printing material science and
nanotechnology is helping to transform
manufacturing healthcare education and
many other sectors of our economy we
created the first-ever undergraduate
major in behavioral economics this
program is led by CMU researchers who
use this fusion of economics and
psychology to tackle some of the world's
most complicated and costly problems
from rising healthcare costs to fake
news and thanks to ID 8 the integrative
design art and technology network we
offer one of the most innovative
interdisciplinary ecosystems for
technology media and the art while our
founders might have not predicted how
quickly Carnegie Mellon would rise to
become a global leader in so many fields
they would surely be proud of the broad
impact we have today we have more than
105 thousand alumni in 145 countries and
grant and degree granting programs in
six continents our global community also
includes Nobel laureates
National Academy members Turing Award
and Stockholm prize recipients
and Tony Emmy and our Academy Award
winners what has remained constant
throughout our history is the strength
of our people
you have fueled our extraordinary growth
the story of this century will depend on
things you do best answering the
questions that will be critical to our
future and pursuing exciting new modes
of creative expression as we face the
next 50 years Carnegie Mellon will
continue to attract faculty members who
are dedicated to discovery creativity
and collaboration our staff will
continue to exemplify the enduring
pursuit of excellence that defines this
institution our campuses will continue
to be the training ground for the
brightest and most promising students
and we will continue to nurture a family
of alumni who bring us tremendous pride
in their achievements and above all we
are a united community
powered by diversity of experience ideas
and talents and as we live by our motto
my heart is in the work we are committed
to supporting one another through
failure and success you are all founders
your role in creating Carnegie Mellon's
legacy over the past 50 years is truly
extraordinary one of the most important
ways we can honor this rich tradition is
to continue to build on everything our
founders have achieved I hope you are as
excited as I am
for what comes next thank you very much